(pen scribbling)
(upbeat music)
- Oh, wow.
- My name's Joey,
I work in fashion merchandising.
I actually grew up in like
a small little farm town
in Arizona.
I'm into like, visual
art, visual aesthetics,
fashion, film, all that stuff.
So if we can have like
some shared interests
that would be really cool.
(comedic piano music)
Oh, wow this is way weirder
than I thought it was gonna be.
Oh, this is really...
Can I touch you?
- [Akanksha] Sure.
- Sorry.
You have like all of your tattoos
in a very similar art style.
She has this really cool(crunching sound)
Sorry, I'm like twisting
your arm all the way around.
I really like this
orange and this mushroom.
Oh my gosh, it's right
next to like the heart one.
I did not need to twist her arm like that.
[crunching sound]
Yeah, it's right there.
- [Crew] What would you
rate this arm out of 10?
- Rate her arm?
A nine, one of the best
arms I've ever seen.
Yeah, for sure.
(laughs)
Another arm? Like, she has two
different art styles on it.
It's like one is like
this big, like colorful
like flowers and the Koi fish and stuff.
And then it's kind of small
but she has like these numbers and stuff.
Seven.
Another arm.
And I can, can I touch your arm?
- [Kenya] Sure.
- Sweet.
For some reason I'm
getting like video game,
like vibes from this person,
but yeah, no, really cool tattoos.
A seven and a half.
Oh, a leg.
Okay. So like pop culture stuff.
That's really cool.
Can I, can I touch your leg?
- [Mindy] Yeah.
- Okay, cool.
She's into like horror movies.
I'm like the biggest chicken
when it comes to horror movies,
so that might not be like,
a huge overlap of interest.
Like I saw The Ring when I was 15
and then went like 10 years
without seeing another.
I actually really like her tattoos.
So probably like another nine.
It has some like Indian influence in it.
So maybe if this is like a cultural thing,
which is really cool.
I've never even seen like nails like this.
Sorry. I'm like just
looking at like her nails
with like her like diamond stuff.
Okay. Tattoos.
It's all like line work and dot work.
Seven and a half too.
- [Joey] (laughs)
Her tattoo looks like she
kind of has like similar
like old school, like horror aesthetic.
It looks like she had
like a cohesive vision from the jump.
Like, I have a sleeve,
but it's just like
really six random tattoos
that I had to like glue together.
One day you'll be cool.
Probably a nine. Yeah.
It's not like I'm rating
their outfits where
they can just
like, "Oh man
if I really wanted to change,
I could look differently."
It's like, these are
things that people have
like a lot of meaning behind.
Hopefully I didn't insult them.
So, I think I'm going to have to
eliminate contestant number (heartbeat)
two
that had like the color
and the flowers and stuff.
- [Jean] Hi.
- [Joey] Hi, I'm-
- I heard I'm a seven.
- I, just your arm,
yeah, aesthetic.
Thank you.
- Sorry.
(playful music)
- She must be so uncomfortable right now.
A sad tofu tattoo,
and next to a telephone?
- [Akanksha] The weed smoking tofu.
- I didn't even know it was smoking weed
but now it definitely looks
like it's smoking weed.
Okay. So yeah, this is, I
know, I know what this, it's
I'm not gonna even say
like the wrong language
that I think it is.
- [Akanksha] They're both Hindi.
This one right here says (indistinct)
directly translated, your lover (laughs).
There's a Bollywood song
I grew up listening to
and I wanted to commemorate
a time when I was
in love with someone
in that way.
- So what is it about like
the American traditional
like aesthetic that you like so much?
- [Kenya] I just think it's
really badass.
- So what is this one, specifically?
- [Kenya] I come from a long line of
very strong Latina women
and so that's kind of
what that inspiration was.
And she also has a mole
just like my mom does.
So it just brings me courage
every day when I look at it.
- Whoa, that's a very
realistic, I'm gonna say Shamu
even though it's probably
just a killer whale.
- [Mindy] The killer whale
is my favorite animal.
- [Joey] It's not Shamu,
it's just a killer whale.
- [Mindy] It's not Shamu.
- What's the quote from?
- [Mindy] It's a poem from Dylan Thomas.
"Do not go gentle into that good night,
Rage, rage against the
dying of the light."
I just fully believe in like
doing absolutely anything
and everything that you wanna do in life
and not holding back.
- Oh
Definitely has like
a religious aspect to it
or a cultural
'cause this definitely feels Buddhist.
Are you Buddhist?
- [Jalissa] No, I'm not Buddhist.
- [Joey] Oh, interesting. What
made you get these tattoos?
- [Jalissa] When I first
got into spirituality,
Buddhism was one of the
first sources that I found
and it had a lot of beauty in
it and I just love the idea.
- [Joey] And the bird?
- [Jalissa] The bird
was just cute (laughs).
- I have a lot of those tattoos.
That were just-
- [Jalissa] There was no reason.
- [Joey] they were just cool.
- [Jalissa] It just fit.
- Oh wow.
Is this jaws?
- [Carmen] Yeah.
- That's really cool.
- [Carmen] It's my favorite movie,
sharks are like my favorite animal.
- "We're all just dying to live."
And that's another shark too.
- [Carmen] That's
actually my first tattoo.
- I really like the jazz tattoo.
I think that's a really cool placement,
especially for girls.
(sighs)
Number two
is gonna be my next elimination.
Hi.
- [Kenya] Hi.
- I really like your tattoos.
- It's okay, it's okay,
it's not everyone's style.
Should we?
- Nice to meet you, Joey.
- Kenya, Pleasure.
Thank you.
- Thanks.
Oh, I have to do one more, right?
I think I'll eliminate the...
(heartbeat)
number four.
- [Jalissa] Hi.
- [Joey] Hi.
- I'm Jalissa, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Was there any specific reason,
just wasn't like your favorite?
- I honestly,
and I know I'm not supposed
to judge too much by it,
It just seemed like a
lot of stuff going on.
Like right here.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] That just was a
little intimidating maybe,
but otherwise no, they look great.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)
- Question specifically for number three.
It's the first thing that I thought of
when this was rolled up,
is how tall are you?
- [Carmen] (laughs) I'm like 5'0,
like, I think. 5'9, 5'10.
(indistinct)
- That makes me feel like
I'm lying about my height.
- [Carmen] Yeah, you know you might be.
(laughter)
I've dated short kings before.
It's okay.
- I already hate that.
What do you do
and how are your tattoos perceived?
- [Akanksha] I am a preschool
show TV writer (laughs)
and a standup comedian.
I guess no one really cares
because they almost kind of look like
a kid drew on me.
(laughs)
- Like doodles.
Yeah.
- [Mindy] So, I'm a full-time
and competitive pet
groomer or pet stylist.
I bathe them,
I give 'em haircuts,
I dye them.
- Where does the competition come in?
- [Mindy] Basically, there's
grooming competitions
across the world.
There's different teams for each country
and we go around
and we compete on doing
show trims on pets.
- [Carmen] So, I am a manager
at a tattoo/coffee shop,
so they're pretty cool with it.
- Yeah.
They seem like they'd be
pretty chill about it, yeah.
- [Mindy] The manager's
pretty okay with people
having tattoos there.
- I guess my next question
is what is your guys'
least favorite tattoo
that you have? (laughter)
And have you ever thought about
getting it like, removed or covered?
- [Akanksha] I think my
least favorite tattoo is
the eye
which incidentally is a lot of people's
favorite tattoo on me.
I don't hate it
and I won't remove it,
but it's just the placement.
I wish I could put something else there.
- [Mindy] My least favorite tattoo is
probably one that you missed
on the back of my leg,
my Disney tattoo.
I don't hate it
and I absolutely do not
wanna cover it or change it.
It's just, I kind of wish that
I didn't get that one because
as much as like each of my
tattoos means something to me,
it's a Disney tattoo.
I'm like, whatever. (laughter)
- [Joey] What Disney movie is it from?
- [Mindy] It's from Lady and the Tramp II.
- Two, the sequel?
The direct-to-VHS sequel?
- [Carmen] Mine's also a Disney tattoo.
- Dang.
- [Mindy] And it's kind of big.
I was 19
and it was supposed to be kinda like a
pirate ship, like an
interpretation of like Ariel
like how they have the
mermaids in front of the ship.
And I was too young to kind of speak
up and be like, actually I don't want that
and I don't like those colors
and I don't like this tattoo.
I debated on removing it,
but I think it would just be so expensive.
- What do people get wrong about you,
just based on your appearance?
- [Mindy] If I'm around younger people,
I tend to get a pretty positive reaction
and people pretty much
don't even look at me.
But I still deal with a lot from
older generations definitely,
looking at me and they'll look at my face
and they're like, "Oh, okay."
And then they look down
at my arms and my body
and they're like, "Oh, okay." (laughter)
Like they don't approve, obviously.
- [Akanksha] As a standup comedian,
I am in a lot of very male spaces
And a lot of the time
when I'm about to perform
someone will always ask,
"Who are you here to support?"
"Whose girlfriend are you?"
Because you can't possibly look like this
and also be funny.
- [Carmen] I'm from Virginia
and for a while
I was like rocking a buzz
cut and tattoos there.
And they were like, this dominatrix,
like goth girlfriend
girl should not be here.
And I was just kinda like,
I'm actually like, I like bunnies
and like, I don't know.
- Whenever I go home to like
my small town in Arizona
a neighbor called, like
some dude with a beard
and a dog is like,
casing like, the street.
And it was me.
I was casing the street and
I was just walking our dog.
So, I definitely can like relate.
(suspenseful music)
I think first elimination will be
(heartbeat)
contestant one.
Hi.
- [Akanksha] Hi.
- Nice to see a hundred percent of you.
- Nice to, yeah, okay.
We'll do that.
- It wasn't so much about her,
like I really liked your answers and like
I think your career is really cool.
More so, I just thought that
their answers were
slightly more in line with just
what I was looking for.
- That's okay.
- I think next,
I will eliminate
(heartbeat)
one.
Tough.
Hi.
- [Mindy] Hello.
Nice to meet you.
- Sorry.
- My hands are sweaty actually.
I'm like, I'll give you a side hug.
- Yeah.
Again, like it wasn't anything
that she said specifically.
- Nice to meet you.
- You have great tattoos.
- Thank you, I appreciate it.
Nice to meet you.
- I just realized I chose
the person that said
that I was gonna be a short king.
- [Carmen] I know (laughter).
So shocked.
You're not short.
- See, it's on a slope.
- I think it's (indistinct)
how's it going?
- Good.
- Do you hug?
- I feel like we should, right?
- Yeah, We'll do that.
- But yeah,
I loved your tattoos,
I liked her stories.
- Thank you.
- Just the attention behind it.
Even though some of the stuff is kind of
like more random that
I expected to be like,
attracted to or whatever
coming into this.
It just seemed like of a piece.
And I just really liked-
- Sweet, Yeah.
I was going to catfish you
'cause you were like,
this is all cohesive and I'm like,
you know,
I'm not saying anything.
- I would love to see you again,
- Cool.
- outside of cameras, that'd be sick.
- Outside of this?
- Yeah.
- Okay, cool.
- You're making this,
you're making this awkward.
(laughter)
- Somehow like flashing him
was like way less awkward than-
- I forgot about that,
yeah.
That's definitely the one that I was like
I'm not gonna ask if I can touch her.
- Yeah.
- For the best
- [Joey] Kanye west tattoo.
This is Dismaland,
it gets mistaken for Disneyland a lot.
Zombie George Washington.
My least favorite tattoo
is this like stupid top hat
villain guy.
Like it sucks.
- [Carmen] (laughing)
- Like everyone's laughing
and they should be,
like I totally respect that.
- Yeah. It sucks.